imagine you've got a door here with a
blue doorknob uh any one of these 10
newton forces will cause the door to
rotate around the hinge or the axis or
sometimes this is called the pivot point
any one of these forces will cause the
door to rotate my question is if you
could exert one of these in one of these
locations which one of these forces if
any would cause the most angular
acceleration of this door and you might
think oh well 10 newtons is 10 newtons
they'll all cost the same amount but
that's not true it turns out we put
doorknobs at the end of doors for a
reason this red 10 newtons at the
outside edge will cause the most angular
acceleration that will cause this door
to speed up most rapidly and this used
to bother me i was like how come this is
getting an advantage i think the best
way to think about it is this even
though these forces are all going
through the same angle so they've gone
through 20 degrees now they've all gone
through 30 degrees now they've all gone
through 45 60 and 90.
even though these forces have all gone
through the same angle they have not
gone through the same distance some of
these forces have been exerted through a
larger distance so just look at it if
you imagine rotating this thing that red
force this outside pink force here
goes through a much larger distance than
that inner yellow force this force has
gone through very little distance
whatsoever and you might think well why
does that matter well it matters because
if you remember work done
work done is proportional to the amount
of force but these are all 10 newtons so
that doesn't really matter here and it's
also proportional the amount of distance
through which that force is applied and
because this outside force has gone
through so much more distance than these
inner forces it's done more work over
the same angle and if you do more work
you input more kinetic energy into the
door it's going to be moving faster for
the same angle compared to what's caused
by these other forces here and this is
why in angular mechanics you can't just
think about forces you have to think
about something called torque the symbol
for torque is this fancy t it's the
greek letter tau and the amount of
torque caused by a force so you need a
force to cause a torque but it's more
than just force you have to multiply or
the distance from the axis to the force
by the amount of force in order to find
how much torque is being exerted by a
given force the more torque that's
exerted the more angular acceleration
you'd get the faster you'd get something
to speed up now you might wonder like
okay i get that more force gives me more
torque how come this is just r and not
like r squared it seems kind of random
maybe it's like square root of r well if
you remember arc lengths from back in
the day arc length is r times theta so
if i'm twice as far away from an axis i
get twice the arc length if i get twice
the arc length i get twice the work done
you get twice the work done you get
twice the input kinetic energy and it
turns out twice the kinetic energy will
give you twice the angular acceleration
this is why everything's just
proportional to r
in terms of torque it's not like r
squared here so for example let's just
say the distance from the axis because
that's what matters to this 10 newtons
here was one meter and from the axis to
the purple force was two meters and from
the axis to this door knob force was
three meters what this torque formula
means is that even though these are all
10 newtons they'd all be exerting
different amounts of torque i'd have to
take the 1 meter times 10 newtons would
give me 10
newton meters so the unit
for torque is meters times newtons but
we usually write it as newton meters if
you buy a torque wrench you could set it
in newton meters or in foot pounds if
you're doing the us system
and then this purple force even though
it's 10 newtons you'd have to take 2
meters times 10 newtons this would exert
a torque of 20
newton meters and the doorknob force
wins the battle because it would have 3
times 10 would exert a torque
of 30 newton meters so the same size
force can exert a different amount of
torque depending on how far away it is
from the axis so one area you have to be
careful this torque technically is a
vector it has a direction it could be
positive or negative if you're doing
full-blown engineering 3d physics
technically these torques would point
out of the screen here out of the page
but for intro algebra-based physics and
for most problems you could usually get
away with just considering
counter-clockwise or clockwise as being
the direction of the torque that is to
say these forces were making this object
rotate in the counter-clockwise
direction so they were all have the same
sign the convention is to call
counterclockwise positive so we'd call
these all positive if there were any
forces that tried to rotate the system
clockwise you'd call those torques
negative you could do it either way as
long as you're consistent most books
pick this is the convention though so
you should be aware of that and then the
last little bit to be careful about i'm
drawing all these forces nice and
perpendicular to the r and if that's the
case you just do r times f if your force
has different components you need to
make sure that the only component you
plug in here is the perpendicular piece
so if this had some weird angle here
you'd only want the piece that was
directly into
this perpendicular lever arm here at a
perpendicular angle uh we'll talk about
that more later for now let's just try
some problems to kick the tires and get
used to this formula so imagine this
example here where you've got the fancy
door you know with a fancy hotel or
restaurant that's a a rotating circle
and you can go in from either direction
this would be a bird's eye view now
imagine you go into the hotel you're
pushing over here you took physics you
know what to do so you exert those 20
newtons over here let's say someone else
comes in from the other edge it's all
awkward and they're trying to go in the
other way and it's a stalemate you're
both pushing with forces but nothing's
happening and that doesn't mean the two
forces are equal if you're in a
stalemate here in terms of angular
motion that means your torques are equal
and opposite they're opposed they have
the same magnitude but they'll have
opposite directions of torque so if
you're locked in a stalemate here that
means the torque that you exert with
your 20 newtons has to be equal to the
torque from the other person so let's
try to figure out how much force would
this person have to exert it's not going
to be 20 newtons they're pushing closer
to the axis here so they're gonna have
to push with more force how much more
force well we can use the formula for
torque to find it the torques have to be
equal if there's no rotation here you're
balanced out if your force is 20 newtons
you're exerting a force three meters
away from the axis that's your r would
be 3 meters times 20 newtons means
you're exerting 20 times 3 so 60 newton
meters of torque that means the other
person has to be exerting 60 newton
meters of torque but there are isn't two
be careful here you always have to
measure from the axis the point where
you're rotating about that'd be 1
meter this door is all symmetric here so
it'd be 1 meter times f and if you take
this 60 newton meters and you divide by
1 meter you're going to get that this
force here is going to have to be 60
newtons so this person is going to have
to exert more force in fact they pushed
three times closer to the axis so
they're going to have to exert three
times the force that you do you have a
three times advantage here in holding
this door compared to the other person
all right let's try one more just to
make sure we understand it let's say
it's now rush hour you know bird's eye
view here same circular door three
people are trying to go through it once
it's going to be a mad house this time i
want to know it's not going to be a
stalemate this door is going to rotate
in some direction i want to know what
the net torque is so just like you can
find that force you can find the net
torque but you got to be careful these
might have different signs you've got to
add or subtract accordingly so let's
start over here how much torque would be
from this 10 newtons well it's exerted
three meters away from the axis so it's
r is three meters so the torque from
that force would be three meters times
ten newtons and since this is directed
counterclockwise i'm just going to call
that positive and i'll have to be
consistent with that choice so now let's
consider this 8 newtons you might think
it would have an oppositely directed
sign of torque from this 10 newtons
because the 8 is down the 10 is up but
it's also trying to rotate this door in
the counterclockwise direction so in
terms of forces this 10 newton and eight
newton are oppositely directed but in
terms of torques they're the same
direction they're both causing rotation
counterclockwise so if i call this
torque from the 10 newton's positive
i've got to call the torque from this 8
newton's positive because it's trying to
exert a torque in the same direction so
i'd have 1 meter is the r for the 8
times 8 newtons would be the torque from
the 8 newtons and then i have one more
force here this five newtons is trying
to rotate clockwise since i called
counterclockwise positive i'm gonna have
to make this a negative torque so minus
three meters the r from the axis to this
five newtons is three meters
multiplied by 5 newtons and if you take
30 plus 8 minus 15 you're going to get a
total of positive 23 newton meters of
torque so this is not a stalemate there
will be an amount of angular
acceleration caused by this net torque
so to recap just like net forces can
cause regular acceleration
net torques can cause angular
acceleration if there is no net torque
that means there is no angular
acceleration the way you find the torque
from a given force as you take r the
distance from the axis to where that
force is applied and you multiply by the
amount of force as long as it's that
amount of force that runs perpendicular
to this lever arm or this r direction be
careful that torque is a vector we
typically count counterclockwise as
positive and clockwise as negative but
if you're consistent you can call
whichever one of these you want to be
positive as long as you call the other
one negative